movie is taking your career a whole new
level um surprise the knowledge i I'm so
grateful I don't know if surprises
driver any gratitude kind of drills at
all it's such a beautiful experience for
me tonight and totally transformed me as
a human being so I'm grateful to film in
to learn so many facilities rod walk
every single person involved the film
was incredibly positive and happy and
had such a gentle kind grateful souls
and
film is an 18 year old and experiencing
that right is also starting my life on
my own it was kind of a catalyst for me
coming into my own I don't think I
switch to this person acted remember
you're happy working
and what I'm sure you're happy working
with such good
oh my gosh yeah George Clooney I mean he
was kind of the head of all the
habitable seminars interbay a vote just
in body such graciousness towards other
Indians and dark is so incredibly calm
drop it and has taught me so many things
about
looking beyond the holes that we
associate ourselves with every day and
yeah it's just keeping it
does that
nexus my character um honestly it was
over in strips I know it's a lame
responsive it's true alexandra burke
such a truthful screenplay and had so
many beautiful words and lends to the
emotion so for me I know it sucks to
come to vons and surrender and listen to
the other actors were saved and who
their words because they were so
perfectly delivered I was able to do a
present respondent
um everyone a secret life is super sent
to me just as I search for them we've
all been given the opportunity to go out
and do other other things apart from the
show and so it's kind of this beautiful
supportive family so much philanthropic
issues you're a football donor because
she's I'm involving Guillermo I think
there's a lot of work to be done within
our society and my my biggest passions
are the environment and health I wanna
stay health I mean a secrets behind
health and our food system and the
secret society I don't want to get into
right now
and call me some genocide going around i
think it's important exciting is it for
you I please
before Shelby not competing with Octavia
Spencer I am so so present she is so
awesome she's such a nice human being
and yeah this is crazy I definitely
didn't expect it and then I got up there
and had I was not articulated and said
um a lot and what are you wearing hello
fight my top is buying us I don't know
nothing about fashion but I know this
guy just seems like a super cool human
diseases for a we're not working on an
age since you got the part in today
my life has changed only in one way and
that is that i have i need to do laundry
room I haven't had time to do laundry
but it is soon after tomorrow we walk
some time to do that some drag now might
get a secret life and I don't have any
movies and story I may need to schedule
working about a direction
uh elevator says he cast us for who we
are as a movie and the best art she gave
me was you're not being ricochet he's
really keen on I'm letting us be as
humans and glasses again and it bites
you need us walk away
I would love to do something dark
or in small I love it if my columns i
love i love emotional scenes i love
people who are struggling with something
I think it's just a joke suppositions my
incredibly happy
my hair oh yeah absolutely um you don't
really fond of the trails left inside
and a lot of the chemicals that will be
pumps through factories and unit clothes
we wear bug if you don't know that
influences Devon there oh sees through
organic compounds and we send half of
our life skipping and if I ever
breathing nozzle or single day there's a
lot of that is love toxins that are
nerve in the air around us and I think
it's important to kind of new to slip
away with the perfect family